so from reviewing your website I believe
you mentioned that the making of the
Black Russian was your desire to bring
light to the drug problem and northern
India that you experience when you were
over there yeah I was um I was taking a
taxi trip up to the northern part of
India and I noticed that my cabbie kept
pulling over and he kept pulling over to
the side of the street and he'd go away
and come back and I had asked him
several times like well what are you
doing man why you keep pulling over and
you have to use the bathroom or what is
it so he's like no I'm just getting my
medicine so then after interviewing him
a little bit longer i found out that he
was actually getting an opium and i was
like i have some i said literally you
can like pull over anywhere you don't
have to have like a dealer or a specific
spot he's like it's pretty prevalent
everywhere in north india so I followed
you know I traveled with him up into the
into the village of areas and up to the
cities of northern India and I found
that in most villages there was a pretty
heavy presence of opium dealers and
narcotics dealers and I started asking
around I asked like well what's the
what's the percentage do you think
prediction here and I pulled an article
actually that at some point there was a
certain category of men like I think it
was like 17 to 24 we're at some point
forty percent of the population was
using opium so I didn't buy that as I
said forty percent of this region is
using opium I sup that's crazy that
means like though you know civilization
collapse and I found it striking that no
one knew about this and this is
happening in the north of India
bordering Pakistan so I talked to a
couple of government officials there and
they and what they explained to me was
that a lot of the the drugs come over
from Pakistan and a lot of the terrorist
activities are funded by this drug trade
the drug trades the drugs come in the
money goes out weapons are bought and so
forth and this sort of sets up all the
weapons trades that happen between
Pakistan and Afghanistan
that and no one knows about the impact
it has on northern India and I said I
thought to myself I thought it'd be
really cool to bring light to this drug
trade but in as in the content in the
contract of a story or a screenplay I
wanted to tell so it was a sort of a
happenstance journey I was taking up
there and I found out about it and I
used this out the backdrop to to the
Black Russian you mentioned that the
Indian news media seems to maybe bypass
yeah these droid yeah they tend not to
focus on it I think the media in India
is very much driven by what the
politicians you know you want the people
to to look at or view so i think the the
politicians have something to do with
this drug trade and this is just a you
know the theory or supposition it's not
I don't know to be fact but after
talking to several people you know it
seems like certain politicians are
getting richer and others are not and
India being of it is a democracy but
it's not it's not the pressing issue I
mean there's other you know other issues
out there the media likes to cover there
so it's not something that's really
known about and I find that I just found
that odd from your time in you said you
spent some time briefly in Seattle oh
you know doing something with psychology
and in yeah undergrad I maybe Washington
so what parallels you save is heroin
usage is fairly high isn't it in the
Washington area alcohol it might be but
but I never came across it I mean like
not like in India so that India was Mike
it was my taxi driver in in in Seattle I
was just hanging around with other
college kids who perhaps alcohol use was
a little high but uh but I don't know
about the other stuff do you see any
parallels between how especially
California culture I mean there's
dispensaries is pretty much on most
blocks aside from residential
neighborhoods
see any sort of parallels between that
or two different animals um I I think
they're they're two different animals i
think the dispensaries are more i guess
they're more government regulated here
in the state whereas in India it's it's
like you know like a crack dealer you
know it's like on the corner of the
street you know it's very shady and then
end up you know there's you know no I
guess quality control what you would say
you